[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
find chris sims pro football talk live
co-host on peacock
former nfl quarterback and football
night in america
all right what came out yesterday after
aaron rodgers press conference where
you were with paul allen of kfan saying
the same thing that
aaron rodgers was told that he was going
to be traded in the offseason
yeah i had always heard really uh going
back to like when this all became
news that from other teams in the nfl
that there was the sense out there that
rogers and his camp
were told they could start to dabble in
the conver the conversations of trading
and that they told him that yeah that
they might appease him that way
so yeah that's where i got that i don't
know i guess it's more news that it just
came out here yesterday or whatever else
but it's something i know florio had
heard behind the scenes
and then as we had this time off and i
you know usually in this time off i try
to catch up with coaches and people i
know around football
of course the aaron rodgers conversation
came up with a lot of different people
like
man do you believe this can you believe
how the packers handle this
all those type of things and yeah i
think that's the one thing that's not
out there kind of in
the public is everything i've been led
to believe from people around the nfl is
he was kind of led to believe
he could find a trade partner uh this
offseason now why didn't he say
yesterday i don't know i don't know i
thought he would say it yesterday
but knowing aaron rodgers too dan i
would sit there and go
he is the kind of guy that doesn't want
to make it look like he wanted outfit
out of there
and he wanted to leave green bay and
look like that to the fan base too
so uh again i know this from pretty
pretty good sources that this was a real
thing
and i wonder if you gave the packers a
mulligan right now
you can you can trade him in the off
season you can change all of this
it would they still have signed up for
this knowing they were going to get him
at least one year
or they could have traded him prior to
the draft
had more people interested got a whole
lot more for aaron rodgers right
right i think they probably could have
maximized more to your point but i think
the other
like big factor in this that
and this is something this is where
another thing i was told behind the
scenes from another nfl
you know person i trust that i'm friends
with here and the fact that
you know the jordan love aspect came
into play with that
with that conversation as well dan you
know
they know he's not ready like we talked
about back in the spring
the fact that he never dressed for a
game last year
i mean you might as well get a mega horn
and yell it out like man he's not ready
he's raw he needs work
so why i think that ultimately too has
led to this like wait let's think about
this again are we going to throw jordan
love out there
and then make it really look like a
disaster if he didn't play well and whoa
we got rid of rogers and here
he is you know messing up our super bowl
nfc championship type of football team
i would have to think that was a big
part of their thinking as well
could you get a first round pick for
jordan love right now
no no i don't no way not not right now
you know
the fact that he hasn't played i think
the league was very iffy about him to
begin with
you know there was some teams that i
think loved his high end talent
you know i know that during that process
and i kind of jumped on him a little
early too because i kind of fell in love
with his highlight tape and some of the
positive things he could do
but as i dug deeper you know there were
issues
and i had too many conversations with
too many different teams who were like
man yeah i see some of that arm talent
and those type of things but he is raw
not the best decision maker there was a
lot of work to be done
i don't think many teams really viewed
him as a first round pick
other than maybe two or three that i
know of in the nfl
i still go back to the ram situation
and i you know i i can't nail it down
and say that it's
it's a report but i mean he that was
right there for him
before they went got stafford if you
would have said to sean mcvay
we can get rogers or you can get sean
mcvay
or you can get uh matthew stafford whoa
well
you're gonna take rogers i mean you're
gonna take rogers but you're also i'll
give you a little caveat you know that
you might not get him as long as
stafford you know that's the one thing
we got to remember too it seems like
stafford's been playing since 1974
but he's only 32 years old you know
that's what's amazing about him
he's got a long way in front of him but
yes i think they do take
rogers if that's like a yes you can have
either one
i would think mcvay does it but i think
it goes back to the conversation we just
had a little bit dan
i don't think green bay was really ready
at that time
to get into trade talks and really go
all in on it
and do those type of things so mcveigh
had to do what was best like
available right now a sure thing and
that was stafford of course he had the
relationship with brad holmes
up there who had just left the rams to
become the new gm of the detroit
alliance and he wanted to get rid of
jared goff as well
in the process exactly that was a big
thing no doubt danny
are you all in on the rams i don't i
don't know if i've got you on record
i don't know i mean i'm i'm all i'm all
in on the rams i mean yeah
oh you're not all in on the rams you
pause i haven't like figured out who
i'm gonna pick to win divisions and do
all of that yes
listen i love the rams football team of
course i think that offense is going to
be better with matthew stafford and all
the things that he can do
let alone now mcveigh can expand what he
wants to call because of the things
stafford can do
i am in it but here's my one issue why
i'm like hesitant
you know i they're an all-star team it's
it's 22 players there's not a lot of
depth on their team
so i always worry about that with the
rams they've dodged that bullet the last
few years but they're a little like the
falcons
except they've dodged that bullet where
you go man the starting 22 is good but
if they lose three or four players
they're screwed and they won't be the
same football team and that's what i do
worry about them and especially i mean
as you know
the nfc west i mean come on it's sick
how good that division is right now
should quarterbacks have a say
yeah to a degree to a degree not that
they call the shots but i think when
you're
rogers brady okay i'll even throw my
homes in that category now but you know
what i'm talking about
peyton manning a few years into his
career not that you have to listen
and go oh that's what you want to do but
you have a conversation with them
i mean jeez dan i went to one freaking
playoff game in the next offseason when
gruden wanted to do things
he would at least talk to me about it a
little bit he wasn't going to listen to
me
but he was going to hear my reasoning
when his coaching career
started to go down though way downhill
right there you know
you listen to a dumb blonde jersey you
got issues
uh but but no i think and i think that's
the point rogers is trying to make a
little bit like
you know this is where i go crazy about
the rogers stuff
all these comments on social media and
everything that he's a diva and a diva
and a diva
and i understand it i understand he's
not perfect and he's not the easiest guy
in the world
but damn i look at him as the opposite
of a diva
i mean they've never done anything
drafting free agency to help him
he signs team friendly deals six year
contracts
it's the opposite of a diva well they do
a good job
in drafting talent here chris you can't
say they
i mean jordy nelson or davonte adams uh
aaron jones the the offensive line
rashaan
gary's like they've drafted well sean
gary what dan
he doesn't play he's behind zadaria
smith and preston smith
you know that's where i know those are
good players i know they are and you're
listen
you're right i'm not trying to like yell
at you i'm just going
there needs to be more to it than that
they do they have a great formula
that's great i understand that but at
the same time
like as i think i've said to you before
i think aaron rodgers the greatest
quarterback
for seen i think brett favre is one of
the top five or six i've ever seen
they've they've won two super bowls with
the two two of the five best
quarterbacks in the history of the sport
to me hey the formula is great but every
now and then you gotta go
wait let me look at the context of this
situation the reality of this situation
and make a move or change i mean you
know again i don't mean to i'm not
trying to hate on anybody here
but brady had a coach that got to rel
rivas
and did all the draft picks you talked
about and then also got randy boss and
made other trades and everything else in
the world
to help that football team and we really
can't say that's ever been done in green
bay with rogers or anything like that
yeah but they're smart enough to draft
aaron rodgers
yeah okay he fell into their lap at 25
that year okay all right i mean yes
that's that's great i'm not saying
they're idiots up there
i'm just saying it's it's worth
questioning the fact that they've won
two super bowls with two of the five
greatest quarterbacks ever
and yes i think when you look at look at
what the chiefs did this off season
they had patrick mahomes and they got
one of the best ride tackles in football
the best guard in football
they traded for a corner who's a first
round pick who's been dealing with
injuries and mike hughes
the green bay doesn't do that stuff we
we send out planes in the air with like
they signed a free agent one of them
yeah holy cow
and that's where i i'm critical of the
packers that if i can use aaron rodgers
to lure free agents why wouldn't i do
that i don't want
exactly yeah i don't want him in my war
room when we're drafting
but i do i want him to reach out to an
offensive lineman or a wide receiver
uh even a defensive player i i agreed
and i think i i think that's again i
know of at least two instances
one a big time receiver who
was in roger's ear because this receiver
used to tell me
he wanted to go there that happened here
in the last few years
the team didn't want to hear it from
rogers you know yeah they don't they
don't i think there's a lot of teams and
i think that's where roger
you can give us the name now i can't i
can't the guy's still playing and he's
still good and i don't want to cause any
issues here and him beat me up or
something but
like i that's where you know i think
he's frustrated because i think he does
have people reach out to him to go
man i'd like to come up there and do
something with you and play up in green
bay
and green bay always just goes well we
only draft guys and they stick to their
formula
and i get it but i don't get it
deandre hopkins
i'm not telling you okay you don't know
my poker face either so you won't know
if i'm lying or not
pro football talk live co-host chris
sims joining us
the camp that is most interesting right
now aside from green bay is
oh wow good question all right well
first off i'm pissed at the jets like
what the hell are you doing that's what
i'm just interested because of the
stupidity of the jets right now that's
where i'd like to go with that i mean
that's
i mean here we are we drafted all this
young
talent we got a superstar quarterback
all they could do was rave about him to
anybody who would listen offspring you
know he's
lasers everywhere this guy's awesome and
now they're going to screw up all the
development because of
money that means nothing and i can't
blame joe douglas or robert sala
that's it's got to be an ownership but
isn't this slotted chris like don't they
know
what they have to pay him like what what
is the hold up here
the hold up is obviously the jets are
trying to do something ownership to me
this is not like joe douglas because
it's not a salary cap issue
or anything like that it's it has to do
something i think with
yeah one of the higher ups above them
going wait we don't want to write that
check right now or give all that cash
i don't know if there's cash flow
problems with the jets or what
it is but yeah you're right the last few
years the first and second picks
is slotted you know what you get they
all get their money in the first two or
three months
and that's it but of course the jets are
doing jets things
uh that's interesting but dan the other
one the 49ers i mean how could i not
49ers are a super bowl team well you
guys they finally got
you know they they signed their you know
they tried
so right is is he gonna eventually start
this year
i would go i would think that there's
got to be at least a package of place
for him
okay i don't know if i'm going to say
he's going to start i i you know i got
to see him play in the preseason and see
you know if he's become more of a polish
passer
if he can un you know handle the nfl
game and all that there is to bring
that comes with that so you know i don't
know but it's intriguing either way
because
they're a super talented football team
with a quarterback
that was in the super bowl two years ago
and a guy that they traded away three
first round picks to get now and they're
having a quarterback battle so i think
that's probably the story of training
camp
if garoppolo had won that super bowl
yeah
would they have drafted a quarterback
probably not i think it buys them at
least another year
maybe two at least like like he's two
first downs away
i know from beating the homes you know i
two first downs away from mahomes but a
full
second half of bad decisions
bad throws plays that were there to be
had when they had to kick a field goal
they should have been a
wide open completion on third down to
george kittle over the middle
and that drive should have continued i
think it's that type of stuff that
has continually frustrated the 49ers and
things like that
but yeah i'm with you i think if they
win that game
of course you buy yourself two maybe
three years uh if you're a super bowl
champ
i feel like we were yelling at each
other today i know you know i'm
yelling i think anyways because i have
ear pods in and i'm usually at my studio
with the mic and all that so i'm sorry i
don't mean to yell at you my fault
you look like you're on a spaceship with
jeff bezos or something whatever
is that earth behind you that's sunday
night football earth haven't you know
you've seen that set back there remember
when you used to be bobby big time and
host
for football bobby big time that in fact
that's what my nickname was in the in
the building
bobby yeah i know i know hey
you're kind of a big deal here comes
bobby big time
i think i left some uh weed in my locker
there so feel free if you want that
oh i already smoked i
found it i got a nose for those type of
things don't you worry
hey and your longhorns yeah
yeah can't beat them join them right
i'm happy i mean come on has there been
like
i mean i'm i'm disappointed with the
texas program i think it's one of the
most disappointing programs in college
football the last 10 years
get out of the big 12. it's a flag
football conference
yeah let's see if we can go you know
play with the big boys in the sec
because that's where it's at for sure
i hope they make the move i really do
how did texas close you
how did texas close me well
i i mean listen matt brown i don't know
how much you've met him right
i love matt first right max amazing i
mean he's amazing
you know i used to say he could sell a
pinto to donald trump like he could do
that
like he is the smoothest talker ever
but either way the school was amazing i
loved the rise of the program right
ricky williams won the heisman right
before the year i went there
i was like man this would be cool to be
a part of the uprising at texas football
again
but the car was an automatic or stick
that you got
they don't give cars to rich kids who
grew up as sons of quarterbacks
they don't do that they loan them they
loan them they don't give them chris
they don't they don't i didn't get
anything down there other than as i've
discussed with you before
what would tennessee have given you uh
nothing i you know i'm too high profile
to to get anything um so i know one day
i'll write a book
and tell you some of the stories and
everything that like went on during
those
other things i witnessed with other
people and other players of course
certain visits can you give me one with
no names
gosh i just was on a visit
once with big time defensive tackle
right
big time defensive tackle and
this school is rolling out the red
carpet
and man anything he looked at he wanted
i want that i want this i want that i
want that i want this i want that
and of course someone whispered in his
ear you know don't worry we'll get it to
you here sometime in the near future so
that
that that's one my aunt wendy and my mom
still get a kick out of them
but you know i'm sorry i can't tell you
i'm sorry i don't want to get the school
in trouble the player in trouble i'm
sorry
the player probably wouldn't care he
really wouldn't but i don't want to get
the school in trouble that's where i
feel guilty
i think we have it well we have the list
of the schools you officially visited
but we will not give them
oh yeah it's all right i i visited a lot
of schools unofficially too so you
wouldn't be able to pin it down to that
sorry no of course not yeah now you know
do you want to tell me that has been
fire miles and money you can visit other
schools it's easier
you want to tell me the wide receiver
now instead
no no man yeah i know you're trying to
really get me today get me in big
trouble no i can't tell you
adam's stealing nope jarvis landry
bigger than is bigger than adam's
feeling and everything like that that's
what i'll say to you on that
bad point okay good to talk to you chris
as always
you you're the man larry fitzgerald
see you goodbye all right that's chris
pro football talk